السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره قالت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه وزاره العدل الامريكيه
ابلغت وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه بفتح تحقيق
في واشنطن بشان وفتي شيرين ابو عاقله
واوضحت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي للنوا
واشنطن وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه باحتمال
لطلبه
وشهادات للتحقيق في وفاته ابو عاقله
من الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وزاره العدل الامريكيه بالتحقيق في وصفه
بالموت المؤسف لشرين ابو عاقله
اوضح حال الولايات المتحده ان تل ابيب تقف
وراء جنود الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولا
انت تتعاون مع اي تحقيق خارجي وانها لن
تسمح بالتدخل فيما وصفه بالشؤون الداخليه
لاسرائيل
اجراء مدير وكاله المخابرات هي المركزيه
الامريكيه سي اي اي ويليام جيرلز محادثات
مع رئيس المخابرات الروسيه السريه ناريشكن
في انقره واقل مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكيين المحادثات التهدفوا لنقل رساله
تتعلق بعواقب اي استخدام من جانب موسكو
للاسلحه النوويه
فلا منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي للجزيره
ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل الدعم القوات
الاوكرانيه ميدانيا واكد ان الرئيس
واحده من يختاروا توقيت التفاضه مع روسيا
قال البيت الابيض من الرئيس الامريكي
بين البلدين يجب ان لا يتحول ابدا الى
صراع وفي قمه عقدها الزعيمان على هامشي
قمه العشرين في بال اندونيسيا ابل بيدنشي
بضروره الاداره واشنطن
المنافسه بينهما والحفاظ على قنوات
للاتصال في حين ندعى الرئيس الصيني لتصحيح
مسار العلاقات بين الولدين وقال ان تايوان
ستبقى الخطا الاحمر الاول لبلاده وانقلته
وكاله رويترز عن وزير الخارجيه الصين قوله
الى الرئيس شيء ابلغا
الرئيسين ستبدل كل الجهود لاعاده توحيد
الصين والتايوان السالميه
قال وزير داخليه تركي ان الدلائل الاوليه
تشير الى مسؤوليه حزب العمال الكردستاني
عن هجوم اسطنبول واعلنت وزاره الداخليه
التركيه القاء القبض على المشتبهي في
تنفيذها التفجير واعتقاله 46 شخصا كانوا
يستعدون لتنفيذ هجماتهم في مناطقه تركيا
المختلفه وقالت تسلطات التركيه انها سوريه
الجنسيه وتدعى احلام البشير وجرى تدريبها
من قبل حزب العمال الكردستاني
واحداث حمايه الشعبيه
انتهى الموجز السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]